I just want to come back to that
huge power play we performed in brussels
with four ministers
four ministers,
one of whom has a bakery background
is a facility manager
one is a teacher and one
his economics degree at Erasmus University
has not finished
nothing after that
teacher wonderful profession baker wonderful profession
study erasmus university
wonderful facility manager this minister background
all beautiful but no legal knowledge whatsoever
just zero just 0.0
with 0.0 legal knowledge neither
on European law
four ministers go there
and then I hear the minister
well they really didn't know what
she happened to four ministers there
yes sorry
but really then I laugh a bit
the Minister
as if that minister
as if those people
those European Commissioners really think so
now there is something coming boys
now we are really shaking
yes sorry
I think then I think so
that seems a bit exaggerated to me